hey London and Dublin it's Rob Charlie
Glenn and Maggie from The Always Sunny
podcast and we have a very exciting
announcement we are bringing the podcast
to Royal Albert Hall for two live shows
on April 16th and three arena for one
show only on April 17th you do not want
to miss these shows we have a lot of
really fun stuff up our sleeves and we
cannot wait to party with you guys it's
your first time heading across the pond
together in 20 years of making the show
so come on out and see us and listen
carefully to this next part because
Glenn definitely does not want to hear
you complain about not getting tickets
he won't shut up about it pre-sale
tickets will be available starting this
Wednesday February 15th at 10 A.M GMT
with the code Sunny that's pre-sale code
sunny and the general sale starts Friday
February 17th at 10 A.M GMT had to be
always sunnypod.com for tickets and
details let me tell you something I
really would love to see you there and
if you're not there I'm gonna lose it